Vì sao băng bạn quay trở lại kênh tin
học Đỗ Bảo Nam Vlog
video ngắn nay đâu Bảo Nam Block sẽ chia
sẻ với bạn cách đổi đơn vị đo từ inch
sang Cm trong Word
ở
phiên bản Word mình đang sử dụng đó đánh
quân 2021 tuy nhiên với các bạn Quốc
khác như 2013
2016-2019 vân vân thao tác để đổi đơn vị
đo từ inch sang Cm bạn thực hiện hoàn
toàn tương tự nhau các bước bạn thực
hiện như sau
bước thứ nhất bạn thích hợp file trên
menu
sau đó trợ option
Bước 2 khi cửa sổ Word options
bạn thích vào men ông ấy van ở phía bên
tay trái
sau đó bạn cuộn chuột xuống phía dưới
sau đó bạn tìm đến dòng có chứa cái chữ
do in unique shop
anh ở đây đơn vị ra mà in và bạn chỉ cần
click để đổi sang một đơn vị khác ví dụ
mình đổi sang Cm
sau khi đổi xong bạn hack và Ok
như vậy mình đã đổi đơn vị từ inch sang
Cm thành công
và nếu bạn thấy video này của mình hay
và hữu ích bạn hay nhất tuần và like và
chia sẻ video để ủng hộ Đỗ Brom blog
đồng thời Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh đấu
Bảo Nam và lúc vào đăng nhập và đăng ký
và chọn lựa tự mình chuông
để nhận thông báo khi có video hữu ích
mới cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin
chào và hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các video tiếp
theo